hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel with today off the like for
years I'm finally doing another gaming
setup slash room to a video that will
include all of my collectibles huge
thanks to Andy for sponsoring this they
gave me my new PC which is what I was
waiting for before I shot this video I
will show you guys that in a little bit
so we're starting pretty much right next
to my doll I live in a studio yeah what
a great doll several locks and this is
basically just a whole way that has a
closet and that's my bathroom we back up
my kitchen is like right here but yeah
we'll get to it so first things first
got this in Japan blue-eyes White Dragon
to cover that electricity box or
whatever it is that they call those
these are all the original Pokemon games
in Japanese with to Chara Zod's in the
back there next family photo there well
I really screwed that up and then this
beautiful Red Dead Redemption
candle it weirdly smells like what you
would expect Red Dead Redemption to to
smell like don't know what that means
but it's like sandalwood II this shelf
is my pride and joy listen I'm not gonna
name every single Batman that I have
here because I feel like a lot of my
audience would be very uninterested in
me doing that but I guess I'll point out
a few special ones I really love these
guys they uh play out sky variant Batman
so basically different artists work on
them and get to kind of recreate Batman
however they want and I just think
they're incredibly cool and unique
obviously if you couldn't tell from the
Shelf in general my thing is that I like
cool and unique Batman so like it is
[ __ ]
there's a lot going on here honestly a
lot of them stacked on top of each other
it's it's careful Tetris work this also
isn't actually every Batman figure that
I have I do have some old back in
Australia that hopefully next time I go
home I can bring with me and continue
the Tetris also all of these little
heads that you can see lying down the
bottom here old joke is they're all
variant joka heads very cool this shelf
is basically all stuff that I still have
boxed because I didn't want to take it
out of the box for whatever reason this
is my newest edition which I'm very
happy with it is a Nicola tan which is
a brand that's going to be inside punk
2077 and then this incredible thing is
me as an amiibo an incredible artist
miss gana Chris I'll leave a link to her
walk below I made this for me so I also
have the new Juke back there I haven't
used it because let's be real it's not
comfortable but I have a soft spot for
it so I just kept it in the box and then
this resident evil' mr. X he is
specifically from Resident Evil 2 he is
indeed mr. X I love him to bits so I got
him this is sdcc exclusive Rowley and
then this guy at the front here I really
love this was handed out to people who
attended a Bethesda e3 press conference
in person and I just love these three
franchises a lot doom fallout and
Dishonored
but I'm happy to have that and then this
last one back here is the only pop Funko
that I own because I don't like them
very much but it's a limited ish and
Kate Diaz so why not and now we're at
the bottom shelf of my bookcase which is
honestly half a little bit of a shrine
to my family but also contains this
beautiful first full figures majora's
mask the only place I could fit it and I
love it seriously it's amazing
I love it so much yeah and it's huge
like to look at other shelves in
comparison it's it's pretty giant and
that is the bookshelf that sits in the
corner of entrance of my apartment
there's not much in my bathroom because
it's a bathroom but I thought that I'd
show you the few nerdy things that I do
have in there hi
stay hydrated we have to hand tools both
obtained in Japan and then over this way
I have this fall out Bluetooth speaker
so sometimes a listen to music when I'm
in the shower
that's how I play and then also just
this Batman snaps you hear that I
couldn't find a place to fit elsewhere
so bathroom in is the only other
particularly exciting thing in this part
of the apartment is I have my shoes all
here but I have this handsome man
sitting right next to them obviously
this is a locust bust from Gears of War
very biggest wolf and I have scared the
[ __ ] out of some people by not telling
him it was there because basically if
you're walking in this direction like
from my door you kind of can't see it
and now to the bulk of my apartment
I guess we'll start with the PC and the
mono because that's what's right next to
the door in the other direction so this
ladies and gentlemen is my ridiculous
monitor yeah it's pretty big
it is ultra wide
damnit reason obviously it's pretty hard
for you to get an idea of how nice a
monitor is or isn't based on a 1080p
video but I can tell you it's a
cyberpunk background and it is an asus
rog Strix xg4 9bq super ultra wide HD
gaming monitor 49 inches wide look at it
oh and it's a 32 by 9 ratio resolution
of 3840 by 1080 running at 144 Hertz the
beautiful keyboard and mouse are both
HyperX and this is a raisin mat I really
like this I just got it in white this is
also LEDs on the sides here so I can
have that change color it's all just
very rainbow basically if I back it up
that's how my desk looks um I'm a big
fan all right let's do PC itself shall
we all so very beautiful
hey handsome how you doing this
beautiful machine fully provided to me
by AMD thank you so much AMD has an AMD
Rison 720 700 X CPU featuring 8 cores
and 16 threads and a max boost of full
gigahertz Radeon 7 graphics card it has
a new 7 M GPU chip with 16 gigs of -
video memory perfect for gaming and
content creation and asus rog Strix
gaming motherboard with RGB lighting and
supreme FX 8 channel audio running on
the x4 70 chipset it's running on asus
rog --though 850 watt power supply with
an LED display to tell you how much
power you're pulling an RGB lighting and
custom power supply cabling from a
foreign customs we've got kingston
hyperx 16 gigabytes of memory running at
4,000 megahertz a kingston hyperx 240
gigabyte fury SSD with RGB lighting as
well a Seagate hard drive with four
terabytes of storage space and cooling
provided by E Casey bu block radiator
and reservoir casein fans what provided
by ragin tech it features an open frame
case with a tempered glass front and RGB
case fans and I'm pretty much in love
with it
thanks again Andy I'm a very big fan I
swear I'll clean up these cables it's
new I've been very busy III happened all
over the place also I have another PC
right here that is also a thing that I
will say I swear I'll get around to
setting up that I am basically planning
to permanently have hooked up to my
oculus I guess now we do the kitchen
it's more than just a kitchen I promise
mostly because of those like the whole
rest of it really just is you know a
kitchen but I'll jump up there and show
you a few highlights okay from left to
right not gonna show you everything but
I do really love this festival figures
in minor Otsu also lights up like the
majora's mask but i haven't looked it in
a while i love that black goku back then
big fan I just like anything that's
different to the norm got some Nia
figures Vanquish that's from saga that
Bubba Fett is super cool I've got some
Charles idea this guy completely custom
made definitely one of my most prized
possessions I have a total video about
him if you want to see that as a mosque
back there
lost achieve century Johanna doc that's
one of my most rare figures which is
ironic
cyberpunk statue from III that's Joker
back there is the one that all of those
heads were from Ganondorf these quarry
the director I've got a wall gave me at
ISTA I really really loved them
and that's pretty much it yeah this is
my family and I love them the rest of my
kitchen is you know the kitchens the
microwave and some drugs I has my fridge
is kind of cool this is also from first
of all Figgis the king of Red Lions does
have battery so basically lights up to
look like it's actual waves because I
got the exclusive edition yeah I
couldn't fit it anywhere else cuz it's
too tall and then my fridge is just
covered in stuff
it's already play a 1 when I saw it at
the premiere cyberpunk take it from last
year have a whole bunch of rock star
stickers down here I got that when I
visited Kojima Productions in Japan this
is from Studio Ghibli Museum I got this
from the Nero tammana devs when I hosted
a panel fandom it packs
I love Yoko taro so much so that one's
really cool the Mass Effect cards
against humanity' cards I've never taken
them out of the box Game Awards tickets
and then this choice lights Dale is uh
traces goggles and then right next to
the fridge is my living room featuring
swords that's a series sword and that
stereo sword from Diablo and then we
flip it around and this is basically
what my home entertainment setup looks
like this is a 65 inch TV I think I
don't remember but I have a webcam up
the top there because I stream with the
green screen which is right here that I
sometimes just pull out and sit in front
of the TV when I stream so obviously
those next books 1 X and a PlayStation
and speakers and sound aw I have my
switch usually talked that right now
it's in my bag because it is that's
pretty much the setup I really like it
something about looking at these 2
things next to each other makes me very
happy I think it might be these screens
is so ridiculous
this is a huge screen especially for
this apartment it's massive but then
look at this one it's insane
oh god I love it so then my bed is on
the floor currently on made and I have
this poster that I got at Studio Ghibli
in Japan
the wall there this wall I have this
giant batwing I think it's 32 inches
it's it's very big that I just managed
to hang there and then up here this is
an anime cell that I got in Japan I
actually uh always assuring people would
get mad at me for this but I don't know
what anime it is it was it says 600 yen
so about six dollars and I just passed
it in a market and really liked it so I
got it
yeah don't know one out of mans from I
just I just really like the art then if
we move down here
it's another bookcase we've got this
epic Master Chief he's a magnetic it's
very cool on top of a hunter obviously
this is the Johnny Walker Black Label
super limited edition from Blade Runner
this is a medieval spawn he actually
broke a little bit so his plot came off
which is kind of Obama got a n7 medal
this is just a thing from when I did a
panel at San Diego comic-con and then
some like I must've build has made me as
a Lego so that's that it's a top shelf
is all DVDs manga signed an iPad this is
the Dark Knight trilogy got some n64
games over here Dragon Ball Kai back
there that's the Studio Ghibli box set
obviously Batman love that um
and ask my pockets you just got to have
them everywhere here we have video games
not as many as I used to have just
because I get them all up digitally now
because naturally tiny apartments I just
don't have space bottom books in comics
again where both of these are concerned
well all three of these shelves actually
are concerned I have a lot more in
Australia sitting next to that in case
you're wondering I have a yoga mat but
I've literally never used my DJ decks
and the master sword and then right now
for context I'm sitting at the end of my
bed again
unmade you don't need to see it and I
have a TV there so uh just for reference
basically there's one TV there and then
there's one TV there they're pretty
close to each other but this is just if
I want to lay in bed and watch TV and I
have actually the Taco Bell Xbox hooked
up to that one
it makes a Taco Bell sound when you turn
it on Plus this chips a Hawaii
controller mmm American branding and
then behind there it's it's a another
curved monitor it's just a spare one and
have that's actually a dog sole statue
that I'm yet to open but that's pretty
much it
um I have fully filled this space I
really love this apartment I like what
I've done with the space I feel like
it's just so videogame II and it's just
so full of things that I like that being
in here makes me happy it gets a lot of
light during the day so that's really
nice but uh yeah I really maximized the
space all right I'm Alana and I will see
you guys later
Oh